hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play back hat
cuz that's right we just ran away from a
monster so we need to get away from the
monster I still hear the music so I'm
going to assume that he's still out
there somewhere and I need to dodge and
avoid him it's awfully dark just like I
expect from amnesia don't know why I
don't think I played a single I'm
there's a custom story that's been any
sort of bright ok going from suddenly
monster music too jarring silence is not
anywhere near reassuring way that's
splash oh I'm stopping it blood button
okay so that's two buttons I pushed I
think I remember pushing another one and
I remember hearing a similar noise so
these are opening something or it's
turning on a machine I'm not exactly
sure either way I'm going away from the
noise so either I'm a complete [ __ ] or
I'm a complete [ __ ]
I wonder which is da another button I
did it
I think the mechanical door should be
open now I remember seeing a mechanical
door what are you talking about what wha
Oh No to sum up here mechanical door
maybe Oh
piercing darkness maybe okay I'll set it
good thing I'm up here with my candle
and whatnot oh you'll never be a dull
cold claw
I never mind I can't do accents is this
ah come at me bro
ruddy for you I'm holding it in the
nerdy ways your bad way that everyone
else holds it huh played in face ting
out
whoa anybody there
ah I guess he's gone they learned his
lesson ah son he's right there
or was he wait maybe I just saw
something I thought I saw an outline of
legs I'm not sure though
come at me bro I'm ready for you all
right I gotta find whatever this
mechanical door is I don't remember a
mechanical core but I guess there is one
somewhere hello
ah this door okay well I guess I should
have been over here and maybe read this
note before mmm maybe Oh tell me what to
do for chambers he wasted my bus
you know I realized it open the door one
without even seeing the door and two
without even being neared the door for
something I don't know
do not proceed it needs to be read more
ominously do not grocery more like more
Santa haha that was new what the hell
was that that's John skull that's what
that was yeah was Y blocked son of a
[ __ ] jeez chamber key that's easy even
couldn't have gone down here are you
even trying I guess no she was upstairs
or her ghostly apparition was uh twist
Eva's not even alive
okay dead naked guy even paintings of
dead naked guys and these I can't get
away from dead naked guys what's in here
dead naked guys I wouldn't be surprised
locked locked doors and dead naked guys
hello
oh yes didn't realize I was that low on
oil uh-huh ah what a joyous day of
course I've been wasting it cuz there
are torches on everywhere I'm actually
been consuming all of my oil cuz the
eyes do it just after a while you just
need to have patience for a few seconds
before it does without busting out the
lantern if I gave you probably go
through the whole game without any loyal
really it's just for your own mood peace
of mind
I'm not going he's going in circle ok
I'm going backwards I'm going backwards
thank you that Simoes man died tommooch
man I made man by mood man I don't want
to do anything with you oh it's a big
circle ok
yeah part times like that I just had the
good boy okay so it's a big circle I
need to obviously find something
something of some sort don't know what
but I'll find it
okay so there's a moose man down here
gotta go bother him for a cup of sugar
or some not sure what where the wind
come from in here how don't make a lick
of sense no oil secretly hidden okay
don't have a lot of job oh that scared
me worse than that skull
ah Jesus guy here [ __ ] off mother God
stop it stop it okay okay I'm okay I'm
okay
let's go let's just see if there's
anything in here come on nothing nothing
nothing okay waste of time waste of life
baki okay knife what weirdo all right
unless Selvig maybe skull you're a
bigger before that's what she said
okay nothing under the beds okay we're
okay let's get out here blood on the
walls not a big surprise
big blockade here of some sort I
understand I understand immediately god
I'm so I'm so in tune to my amnesia
senses hurt they're up no no yeah there
we go
anything in here no way to get out
well anyway we're gonna ignore that ever
happen yeah well this looks bad let's
just take some loud down and I'm shooted
in my arm to recover from that fall that
I just took the chat dead naked guy that
dead naked guy that's a dead naked guy I
can I can tell from the ripples that's a
dead naked guy
so is that that's one two whoa go on the
other way oh that's a lot of dead thank
you guys oh no we're go to two eyes in
the darkness screw you f off was this
this was this oh it's an arm never mind
I thought it was something useful never
mind okay Wow how about no oh oh man
yeah that baby face never used to
disturb me all that much but recently
it's been horrific why did I even go
down there was there a point Jesse I
need to get out of there somehow I guess
it I didn't see anything that I could
grab was all underwater was it was it oh
it's a lantern I thought I was a face
looking down at me oh man
okay so this is obviously the block door
why did I need to come back this way was
it blocked up for some reason was it
really an obstruction that suddenly
appeared that I needed to nevermind you
know what never mind I'm just getting
out of here I got a key of sorts regular
key don't know what it's for what is it
for what is it for anyway wait wait a
minute was this I needed to find Eva but
why am I here why did I need a regular
key why did I need a regular key there
must have been something else down here
oh I thought this was the door came out
of oh okay here we go
light some stuff used to tinderboxes we
got plenty of them
- helicopter go to Baba God the doughnut
don't do much oh hello baby oh I feel
better now mm-hmm oh you want me to get
in the bat off oh oh come on in the
water's rather cold actually sorry it's
a little shrinkage ah anyway so moving
on don't know what that weird noises
Alice let's refrain from going further
down before we explore the area locked
and oh babe with splish splash
especially okay locked over here who
knocked this door in these are lit
there's not a lot of light here well I
thought that was a face - okay
san Bao ting like I need it what's this
oil sanity potion and a thumping arse
natural gas to spark the door you'll
need to call finger longer so men start
to work and ease the door off there
should be none call the cells because
the priests will have to warm up their
own Chelsea
oh man now am I gonna drag five chunks
of coal up here to this oversized
lighter oh you gotta love modern
technology they shrink that giant
machine into it little handheld thing
damn you blood doors blowing open in the
wind Jana Rana anyone ever watched
Yahtzee his his review of amnesia is
amazing I love it I love Yahtzee zero
punctuation I don't know the game
Yahtzee but you know hi what's the deal
what's - what's your deal what's your
deal what's your deal guy here oh boy
these aren't cells these are torture
chambers ja please oh boy I'm not
another Iron Maiden jump-scare incoming
maybe oh look it's Cole hey buddy God
right what is that
what is that no give me my coal hey Mike
all good hey what that well gotta carry
why I'm playing there
oh you son wait no maybe that's where
I'm supposed to put it ha ha ha where am
I someplace else
shop cool no cool fun run hurry hurry
run Oh God's amazed okay I am supposed
to put the coal in there okay I thought
it was very worried for a second there
the shop shut up call got it a mush burn
your face off with this coal if I can
hold it with my hand
take it away yeah come over here let's
go to the circle buddy let's dance
jackass I see you you see me come on
I make noise yeah yeah ah there you are
okay come on come on come on new buddy
come on boy
alright okay man that guy's a iPad
finding is terrible
it's falling apart it's gone all the
wrong ways wait no I probably wasn't
let's put that in the same one or wad I
yes I don't know I'm probably breaking
the game at the moment I don't know what
I'm doing it's really dark that's better
stop banging on the doors they're very
expensive
is that a cry of fear yell I think that
is that's oh this is the other door this
sad that sounds very cry for as this
whole deal sounds very cry fear you know
the house my best impression on it aloof
were I think I think I'm getting better
at haha finally call gimme doesn't it I
mean I'm not losing my mind a by
descending in the cry fear hello mister
dissing hair go i dick I'm running out
of time ah not this visitor was too
stupid to put it in the furnace what ha
ha ha good way go hey OH
almost got it to Steve one more one more
one more ha baller black mouse that
okay I'm definitely not kidding that
sounds exactly like Crabtree okay that
was five so did that do it or did I
Hodge
ha ha ha okay so did that do it or did I
just screw up the game by trying to jam
them into pipes they weren't supposed to
go in shop let's go come on
half that chunk fudge I wasn't supposed
to put him in there was I yes 5 5 -
markiplier doing the wrong thing way too
much come on ah
oh god I'm dumb I am dumb but I can't
get him out of there I can't take it out
of there can I hang on
all right anyway actually I'm a lot of
time I've been dragging it on farther
than I should have anyway but anyway so
I'm just gonna sit right here in the
light so Annamma stand right here
with my baby in the pool oh so thank you
all so much for watching click the
interface with Morgan you see I've done
and as always I will see you in the next
video
but
Oh